[Música]
y
en washington se espera que la cámara de
representantes- a su regreso del receso
de mitad de año continúe con la
discusión del proyecto de ley para una
reforma estructural al departamento de
policía a nivel nacional y esto
básicamente busca crear más recursos
recursos federales y jueces para que
investiguen estos incidentes en los
cuales en medio de detenciones de
policía personas pierden su vida pero
igualmente se espera que también esto
brinde la posibilidad de que los
policías que se ven envueltos en estos
incidentes no sean reasignados a
diferentes estados y continúen con sus
funciones así que esta será una de las
prioridades de los demócratas en la
cámara de representantes
[Música]
en el estado de nueva york continúan las
protestas contra la violencia policial y
el racismo de manera ininterrumpida
desde el pasado mes de mayo cuando el
afroamericano george floyd perdía la
vida a manos de la policía pero sin duda
en los últimos cinco días se han
concentrado en la localidad de rochester
allí vivía la última víctima
afroamericana que muere en una detención
policial
danielle brut un hombre afroamericano
con problemas de salud mental pues bien
precisamente allí parece que las
manifestaciones están empezando a surtir
efecto porque el jefe de la policía y
toda la cadena de mando de aquella noche
en la que daniel bruch perdió la vida
acaban de renunciar a su cargo dice el
jefe de la policía que renuncia a su
posición porque la caracterización
errónea y la politización de las
decisiones tomadas tras la muerte de
este afroamericano no casan con su
manera de ver el cuerpo de la policía
una decisión una renuncia que llega
precisamente tres días después de que el
fiscal general de nueva york- haya
creado un comité para investigar lo que
sucedió aquella noche en la que daniel
proud perdió la vida
[Música]
aquí en california continúan algunas
manifestaciones y protestas aisladas por
la brutalidad y el racismo
mirando así pero hechos concretos una
ley para combatir este problema sigue
sin darse el senador demócrata steven
bradford había propuesto una ley en el
congreso de sacramento aquí en
california para hacer 12 modificaciones
al departamento de policía y del sheriff
pero sus colegas no lo apoyaron no
encontraron los votos suficientes para
que esto se convirtiera en ley por ahora
simplemente grandes ciudades como san
francisco la misma capital sacramento
los ángeles y san diego han decidido
hacer recortes al presupuesto de policía
y del departamento del alguacil incluso
casi 50 millones de dólares se le
quitaron al departamento de la policía
de los ángeles por su parte de actuación
a sus agentes para evitar que cometan
excesos
[Música]